what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today Brooklyn Nine-Nine season 5
episode 8 return to Sky fire John how
are you I am fired up G pies in the
skies how are you I am uh meatballs
raining from the clouds ladies and
gentlemen be sure to leave a like on
this video if you end up enjoying it
that would mean a lot also as always
thank you to everyone who's joining us
on our patreon page because full-length
Reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy available for a super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page become
a super sexy reject today to check out
everything we got to offer that's
exclusively there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
let's see this episode is all about
hey Jason guess who just called me the
Jerky Boys they're back no no DC parlov
he's in town for legend con and he has a
case for us oh my God Legend Khan our
love can you write those Skyfire books I
thought he turned out to be a jerk yeah
but ever since Jake and I saved his life
he's actually been very nice oh that's
right favorite moment in the series the
summoning of Bella Castro third favorite
when you thought kalar had been
swallowed by the norlith but he had just
switched armor with his family the
betrayer in the Battle of our cat oh no
I know you think it's dumb but Skyfire
is actually very smart and dark and
adult on our way there should we sing
the Elvis hunting song sharpen your
swords and string your bows the beasts
have gone
hahaha
oh look at this place I can never get
into any of this crap it's garbage I
mean what is it that you do in your free
time it's so cool fixable cars and sell
them to celebrities that's why I'm
friends with Tom Hardy
diversity and fantasy writing oh the
line starts here real diverse diversity
panel remember people always ask me
where do you get your ideas and honestly
bubble I've actually been writing a
novel wait what you're writing a book
for fun like I'm not trying to be an
author I don't even know how to go about
doing that barloff you should show it to
parlof he could probably get it
published no do it you are a great
husband father detective painter dancer
and you're so Jack you have muscles on
your back everyone has back muscles Jake
my back looks like the inside of a spoon
but the point is you're great at
everything ew I'm not showing power off
my book okay all right here it comes I'm
just drop it it was fascinating
especially to Terry he's a writer and he
wrote a book would you read it
Jake what Terry you need to believe in
yourself like when morzak answered the
sorceresses riddled she turned him into
a tree Jake yeah a tree that became the
handle of priminius's ax our love is so
far away already yeah good cow let's go
after him yes sergeant said we're
hosting a forensic Sciences course talk
by Dr to Ronald Yi he is a rock star man
could tell how long a corpse has been
decomposing just by studying the maggots
inside I'd like to see Barbra Streisand
do that it sounds interesting can I sign
up yes
you can
[Laughter]
we receive board certification which
makes us eligible to receive a grant to
open a field lab in the precinct but
but what I really course material to my
experiences subjective learning
Millennials I know it's important so I
promise I won't tell any story sometimes
they do come in handy one time all the
boils were in this fungus Cavern and
this massive Here Comes happening in my
room right over here I need just a
moment to clean up I had a female
visitor in earlier today dressed as
concubina she got some ears of green
body paint all over everything
that's all I'm saying I can't believe
you told him about my book I'm sorry
Terry but now DC barlov is going to read
what you wrote how cool is that it's
pretty cool right yeah he's gonna steal
it story of a gorgon Warrior awesome it
betrays his bloodline how could he can
marry a cloud princess you did it for
love even though their families are at
War oh no send it over to me and I'm
gonna stay up all night reading it it's
only 150 Pages I'm gonna stay up all the
next three nights reading it
good morning everyone thank you for
having me at the 99 so I am late just
had to deal with some family issues
cousins right
okay before we get technical let's talk
a bit about the history of blood does
anyone here know any hemophiliacs now
they played a vital role in the
development of modern forensics then and
leeches my cousin torfald is a
hemophiliac and his wife is a leech
farmer I say wife but it's a common law
marriage for the longest time Boyle
wedding ceremonies were not recognized
in the state oh my I feel like that'd be
good
person left is known we have your book
pay us five hundred thousand dollars in
the next 24 hours or we leak it online
the first five chapters are now up we've
been downloaded 85 000 times Well we
should probably go online and read those
chapters in case there's some clues in
there
[Music]
Landon Lawson he writes The
shadowbringer Saga it's garbage when we
have a rather public bet about who's is
going to sell better if this book fails
that's the end of Sky fire let's go take
this son of a [__] down he's pulling
another scam let me guess you're here
about the stolen manuscript so you admit
you did it someone stole my manuscript
and I know who it was DC parlov by
zorton's sword
I grab thar's Hammer you literally want
to steal your book The Sky fire cycle
makes the shadow bringer cycle look like
the beastwarm chronicle you know what my
books say something okay I was the only
one brave enough to tackle elf
molestation guys calm down oh my God
Jesus but we will need you to both
generate actual lists of people that
might want to hurt you 24 hours to
figure this out but if we don't are you
willing to pay the ransom and do
anything to get my book back I mean you
understand you're a writer I called you
a writer Terry well Terry's broken right
up those lists we're on the case
[Laughter]
he or she be able to
I was gonna vote me too I mean I know
the plaster can dry out your skin but as
a boil I'm aggressively moist well you
gotta close that mouth Boyle put some
straws in his nose we're gonna go
confront him and get the laptops back
maybe we can see if Carl I've read my
book yeah I mean it's been less than a
day maybe don't get your hopes up don't
worry I don't have any expectations I'm
good I'm going to read my phone just in
case the publisher calls I mean somewhat
geez oh no I couldn't sleep last night
so I started reading Terry's book and
it's terrible so what are you gonna do
about problem I don't know I don't know
what uh dude how to do sex how much
should I be flapping my arms around not
much right well that settles that I knew
that Amy was wrong
okay now that the plaster's drawing
you'll see why we lubricated the
subject's face with Vaseline first
I thought it was blood at first uh what
if someone forgot to lubricate before
applying the plaster becomes impossible
to remove the mask without literally
skinning the subject alive it takes five
days for the plaster to Slough off on
its own it was an unacceptable level of
incompetence oh what a satisfying
conclusion in that story
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know Captain he seems pretty
upset hold on
oh God
look how happy he is now
yes you're welcome boy that's disturbing
yeah it's like a horror movie villain
slasher villain you hate them for
sleeping with your wife well this is
awkward we should probably just Jessica
she's here did you sleep with DC parlov
and Landon Lawson why would you do that
you've ruined our marriage you know this
seems like a conversation for just you
too so here comes a child oh Christ
looks like we're back at the nail
Caverns did you just say the nail
cabinets why didn't you tell me you read
my book Jake you hated it what
you you humiliated me in front of my
hero oh this is bad oh geez you guys got
a million dollars together on 24 hours
notice yeah but to liquidate my Bitcoin
I would have thought you'd be flushed
with cash from the sky Fire TV series oh
wait that's right how's the
shadowbringer film coming along Howie
Long still playing both twins all right
how we long if someone grabs it Rosa
Peralta and I will converge we'll be
positioned around the room in Disguise
it's not gonna work I don't own a nerd
costume you are already wearing one you
naturally dressed like the female bounty
hunter and every steampunk novel yep
building goggles I have welding goggles
in the cars
to solve that problem we would use fluid
Dynamic analysis I'll look like her it's
so funny it was urgent Police business
bunch of kids are being held hostage so
he had to go deal with that your
husband's on the phone he wants to know
how long you're going to kiss for
tonight your husband didn't really call
I wasn't sure what gay guys talk about
on the phone how'd I do Scully what do
you want
no he's right Terry had a tone Terry had
a big time tone don't worry I bet he
hasn't even read your book yet it's been
two hours almost in front of this line I
don't even know who I'm waiting to take
a picture with Bran Stark pass
all right Raven there we go
is that his name just say color uh then
how will you know which color I'm
talking about it's very common name in
Skyfire it's like they're John
I will now be color
why are there so many colors costume
contests just ended that's why he waited
until now to pick up the money I lost
him free NYPD let me see your hands
doesn't have the briefcase I got the
wrong color take him down wow
can't see anything at all and it's
really scary being touched why would you
leave that windowless Supply Closet we
locked you in yeah I was trying to get
to the locker room to steam the mask off
in the showers you were trying to help
us well I know how important the course
was to you not anymore
huh
by the way detective Jeffords while we
were waiting I had an opportunity to
read your manuscript oh don't worry
about that oh it was great truly
fantastic I mean it was so fresh you
know it had a really unique point of
view I sent it onto my Publishers thank
you for allowing me to read it he's
gonna steal it see part of love my
writing you were wrong and being wrong
never felt so right oh that sounded cool
did let's make up a hit song being wrong
never felt so right with The Adams
Family staying up all night yep I was
right
it's on Netflix
Terry's writing sucks parlov is lying to
him why I don't know because Lawson and
parlov stole their own books Terry is
Gomez I'm cousin it you are Wednesday
let's do this
do this [__] spent an hour arguing over
the name of the dragon and The Hobbit
small small
[Music]
it's smog by the way point Lawson but
yes
why they think we'll never suspect them
of being in cahoots oh but they kahooted
Rosa they kahooted they would have to
know he wrote up the book beforehand I
thought you said your friend removed his
mask and left I forgot to lube up his
face that is incredibly careless I know
and it means we won't receive our
certification unless my honesty no it's
off the table and I'm okay with that
my cousin Donna has a genetic disorder
where her lips are made of cartilage
meaning her mouth is technically a beak
no I don't talk I want to hear it Boyle
tell us about your cousin's beak well
she runs marathons to raise money for
there are only two of them they're her
kids oh I think that our love hated my
book he only said he liked it so I
wouldn't figure out he and Lawson stole
their own manuscript I got a warrant for
Carlos browser history he searched how
to liquidate Bitcoins three days before
the laptops were stolen man I bet that
browser ugh question them and they
confessed I can't go to prison okay I
know I seem tough but I'm not I went to
Bennington I'm sorry parlov didn't like
your book no it's okay at least I won't
waste any more time trying to be a
writer no yeah I mean yeah no more I
look back at my old cases and I can't
believe how long it took me to figure
things out yeah but you worked on it and
you kept working and now 12 to 40 years
later I don't have a good sense of your
age you're a great cop
to keep writing I mean you might not
become a huge famous author but you'll
get better and if it makes you happy it
can't be that bad Cheryl Crow she's
great I won't apologize and who knows
Claire esselgorn didn't start writing
the first Crimson portal novel until she
was 60.
oh kept reading it because it's so good
Rosa yes you did get hooked you Big Nerd
this heroin is My Heroine
I love it speaking of which I was a bar
you want to go read the new Sky Fire
book
I don't know I mean he's such a bad guy
do you even like his books anymore
[Laughter]
separate the art from the artist that's
right even cops do it skip off into a
bookend
yeah how's your writing going John it's
uh it's not as prolific as Terry's I'll
tell you that I'm sorry to hear that
it's been a long time since I've cranked
out 150 pages but you know I mean it's
going okay in the short form
it's good here I like writing uh yeah
short form things uh come come easily I
like my story no one cared oh I cared I
clicked it a hundred times so you feel
better
I didn't read it though
all right I want to save it for the day
you dropped the book anyway go on with
your thoughts that was fun it was
did you have fun I did cry I cried the
whole time I didn't stop crying we hit
play and it was just oh
I could have gotten a plaster cast off
my head with tears Alone
um
I've never done that but I've seen it
happen in person and it looks
claustrophobic
I could handle it I bet you could I was
once submerged underground for 12 hours
for a fifty dollar dare what
do tell I just told you what is where
were you Underground
at the Hollywood Cemetery really yeah it
was an all-day influencer event
sounds really fun and I signed a waiver
and everything okay so you're right for
influencers were there
a bunch of influencers were underground
for 12 hours or 15 seconds or separately
no I had the idea was to do a post how
many underground Chambers today was to
promote Edge of Tomorrow sure yeah that
sounds like it makes sense what is it
you you you really feel like what it's
like to die and then repeat yeah and
then if you're living on the edge of
tomorrow yeah sure yeah yeah it was
great and I recommend it for everyone I
think you come out a stronger person in
the end do you only recommend it if 50
bucks were involved oh yeah don't do
anything without money incentivizing for
free yeah
so there's that
how's your writing coming along
this is
uh or we can keep that bit going but I
feel like the internet has heard it I
ran in a couple weeks it's been really
uh Weighing on me oh
when your life is really about writing
and then you don't write
every day feels like you're failing and
falling behind sure yeah yeah
because there's like there's always
something that you should just write
just write write anything
yeah and then it's crap then you're like
ah I should never if I show I lost it I
lost the views my talent is gone I lost
it
uh gee you're a good writer it happens
man it happened forward to reading your
scripts
or whatever it is usually
my fantasy pornography dude I bet it
would be but it would be pretty creative
grief is usually the background yeah
yeah yeah a horror grief infused erotic
Family character yeah yeah building to
the finale Crescendo real heavy core
wounds
character backstory
um
there's a there's a version out there
there's a message board for that
so the so that's uh so let's talk about
the episode itself I like that
that's good it's fun I like seeing
learning that Peralta is actually a
full-blown dweeb this time because first
they were like oh I read the book
Skyfire book that makes sense and now he
knows like all about Game of Thrones now
yeah he seems like where did this come
from he was still an idiot in every
other episode
how does he become a savant just for
reading fantasy novels and also Cujo
yeah because yeah they start and he
seems clearly familiar with all the
other sagas as well as in the universe
this is a difficult book to read
difficult books to read sure they're
dense and and is Gina gone I was just
wondering that it just hit me right now
we haven't seen her since like the first
episode or haven't you seen her Ultra
season yeah I mean is she in the opening
credits yeah she is I'm sure I'm pretty
sure I think I clocked her this episode
I don't think they've removed her maybe
she's just on maternity leave I mean
that seems like the most likely thing
but but yeah it is really the biggest
scam every woman's ever pulled so you
can sit at home and do nothing with your
baby yeah she is in the opening credits
but yeah it struck me I was like we
haven't done anything with Gina in a
long time I think it might have been
like the end of the last episode it sort
of floated through my mind I was like oh
wait
that's right because there would be
it hit me that like so many of these
episodes would have had a Genus yeah
yeah and this episode I feel like it
stands out because like she would be
berating them for even being interested
but I haven't missed her
no it hasn't I mean yeah it took me
took episodes to realize
I mean Gina is a character I think that
that works in Doses and isn't you know
made to be like the lead character so I
think you can sort of remove that
element and not suffer too much because
you can give some of those things to
Rosa I feel like the Energy's been
moving along better now and the Rhythm
and stuff sure it's a little less toxic
and negative in the workplace you know
what I mean I mean just
[Music]
did you guys know I mean like do you
guys Miss Gina if you've made it to this
point in the video
or did you have that same realization oh
[__] there's no Gina
I feel like seeing in the opening
credits I'm like yeah do you know let's
hear this episode
gets paid yeah yeah and maternity leave
biggest scam
scam
can't wait till AI replaces mothers so I
found out my mom took a maternity leave
I've never visited her ever again I will
take no leave on Yorick ashamed to be
born from your womb you should have had
me in a one of those baby things at work
at the cubicle yeah so yeah okay
um
that whole thing with the writer
kind of predictable yeah yeah and I mean
for those guest stars fun but also like
he made me want a little bit more
craziness especially the other guy yeah
Rob hubel yeah like he's like a
full-blown comedian yeah totally and he
often shows up to play I don't know big
or despicable he often plays like unlike
[__] [__] yeah pretty much
unlikable douchebags
and certainly riding that line here but
yeah it seemed it felt like oh cool he's
gonna have moments to shine but he's you
know he's he's there he's he's it's fun
they're funny but it's not like oh yeah
big memorable part of the episode yeah
I feel like the most memorable aspect is
is them getting into costume and Rosa
becoming unlocking her inner nerd you
know
it's not easy when you tell a friend
that you don't like the writing
no that's why I've lied to John for
years sure that's why I keep doing it
because your deceits keep me going gee
string me along
but
I mean now you find what's good you look
at what they're going for and then you
give
like
guideline
advice I think you don't want to like
just change it so here's how I would
write it yeah
here's what worked here's what didn't
work as much
or been the brutally honest feedback guy
it sucks there's people who do that
yeah I hopefully that's constructive
no it's only constructive I think in the
in the grander scheme of like well
you're gonna have to be equipped to
handle that too but I don't think it
helps like the actual qualitative Act of
your writing getting better yeah yeah
it's more for the Hustler it's more for
yeah the party use gotta shop that [__]
and be not unafraid to show it and uh
I guess Rosa does dress like that I mean
they clearly modeled that author after
how Rose the the front cover with that
after Rosa yeah I think that was her
that was probably posing
um but uh but the story with boy
accepting Boyle from who he is I was
had nothing to do with it it's the
weirdest B story because it has nothing
to do with
like thematically at all yeah with
other than storytelling I suppose and I
guess you could draw the Vegas
connection between costuming and
having a plaster cast made on your head
yeah spending a lot of time encased in
some other thing what became of the guy
though
who did take the briefcase
something become of that individual I
don't think so because they probably
just paid that guy right
they don't need to arrest that guy no
because he's just part of their
I mean all you have to do is pick up a
briefcase I suppose so that's an
interesting legal question because
technically even if that guy was
contacted by these two authors to Aid in
their scheme you know these technically
complicit is uh uh
that's true that's true we should have a
b plot of them unpacking this with the
guy like I didn't know man they said
they'd killed my family if I didn't pick
up this [__]
and it's like oh yeah you're free to go
that's heavy John hey man these writers
are uh they get Despicable you know
they're they're so rich you know they
gotta find their kicks other ways to
have all these AIS where they can write
the books for them I know you can just
plug every other book in the franchise
into the AI and then have it come up
with all right first chapter of my next
one
oh dude and then after they're dead they
can continue they can use the AI to
continue
just like they're doing with music right
now
Timberland or somebody owns some kind of
AI thing that gives him or may give him
if they approve it the right to just
make Notorious B.I.G songs or something
like that
cool that sounds I can't wait to do that
good idea
I think there's a lot of nuance to the
debate around AI but that's a thing
where I'm like I'll pass on that no
thank you please don't what's that yeah
and how would that be spec like because
they're treating it like it's a
collaboration and I'm like how is this
special you're cheating they're dead
yeah like leave it be because no one's
gonna be like go to the real biggie pen
these lyrics yeah
I don't know who that's for that's weird
yeah it's ghoulish man
sticky because like the whole point
would be to ride the Nostalgia of the
super fans who still listen to Biggie
unless people are like this new song
from biggie which sounds like a song
from decades ago it is great yeah
this uncovered gem from the early what
90s all right guys well
do you write have you ever have been
heavily criticized for the way you write
Sarah took like a champ in the end he
did he really did he knew how to
realize that and you just it was your
first go at it yeah you gotta keep on
pounding and folding the sword you know
someone who's working on their first
book
and they've already got a publisher
talking the very first book what that
they're they already had a publisher
meeting and they're they're like yeah we
want to aim to publish this this is
really good it's the first book I've
ever read it what a confidence booster
that was just like in their 50s
I mean how many years of writing have
led up to this point I'm just like I
guess I'll just start writing yeah for
the first time it took a story if that
happened in his life and he told it from
third person point of view wow
dramatize it a little bit and add some
umph do I know this person you might met
them once and then they
and and it's apparently it started out
great it is well they're like no I've
just read a lot so I just tell them to
write a movie about his life that was
great unheard of yeah that's the dream
yeah one shot and he's freaking whoops
that but I've heard that this person's
I've heard them just tell so many
stories about their life to me and they
and I tend to just shut up and listen
because they are so engaging
and they know how to like paint a
picture and they are really engaging
when they're telling the story like they
become very animated and is very
engaging so I'm like oh yeah I could
definitely it's the kind of thing where
like you hear their stories or like you
should write a book based on your life
so they'd already know how to tell a
story interesting like if I'm telling a
story about my life I have a harder time
just
get like self-conscious I don't try to
like animate it or sell it so yeah yeah
I don't want to make puff my life more
than I do I don't want to yeah I don't
want even in like in friend circles I
try to be really casual like what I'm
talking about right now
yeah I know everybody he knows how to
like really sell it with like the
characters like I was in the moment and
then this happened yeah
oh yeah
so
all right guys so let's talk with you
soon thanks for being here
foreign